I presume that before you engaged in the
Duck Dynasty series you guys weren't
actors and you didn't have a lot of
experience while certainly producing
like a half scripted family sitcom so
how did you manage to keep it funny and
spontaneous at the same time that you
managed to impose some sort of narrative
structure on it and who was responsible
for that how did you do that it was just
Talent from God
humility is that the right order
you know I I mean for me it was about
I'd watch shows and so what I thought
was funny
um
and like Seinfeld or you know I watched
shows I was like oh it's really funny
how they did that and so I tried to just
do that remain in myself